il y a quelques années c'était encore
une insulte de cours de récré quelqu'un
de limiter mentalement je ne suis pas
évidemment autiste depuis ça a bien
changé l'autisme est devenu une fierté
Elon Musk Anthony Hopkins ou Greta
thunburg le décrivent comme un super
pouvoir
sur Tik Tok qui a des tests improvisés
pour savoir si tu fais toi aussi partie
de satellite plus intelligente et plus
émotionnelle que la moyenne
moi ce qui prétendu bon il y a beaucoup
de fouilles d'idées reçues dans ces deux
visions je suis moi-même autiste
diagnostiqué et je vais tout vous
expliquer l'autisme est-il toujours
visible il y a encore quelques années
ont classé les autistes en plusieurs
catégories
4343 X
1234 5 3 5 9 2 6 2 c'est un génie il y a
pas d'erreur il y avait l'autisme des
surdoués avec des gens incapables de
socialiser mais pouvant lire des livres
en 10 minutes ou retenir par cœur la
carte d'une ville en la voyant qu'une
fois comme dans ce documentaire il y
avait l'autisme lourd avec des troubles
du développement cognitif difficultés à
parler à bouger
c'est une façon d'être
un Guillaume et à la forme la plus
célèbre l'autisme aspergeur la version
soft entre guillemets aujourd'hui cet
appellation est rejetée de joie pour
sous le docteur asperger autonosie et a
participé à l'euthanasie d'enfants
handicapé moyen mais surtout on s'est
rendu compte que l'autisme se catégorise
mal que chaque personne avait ses
particularités du coup en 82 leur nawing
propose l'approche en TSA trouble du
spectre autistique avec beaucoup plus de
diversité mais aussi des limites plus
floues par exemple les troubles de la
tension TDAH les hyperactifs la dyslexie
ou les HPI ont potentiels ont beaucoup
en commun avec l'autisme ils peuvent à
moindre de regret avoir des difficultés
dans l'interaction sociale et la
communication ou la présence de schéma
restreint dans les comportements et les
centres d'intérêts on détaille juste
après soit selon le dsm5 les deux
piliers qui caractérisent le TSA pour
certains on aurait tous quelque chose
d'un peu autistes en nous sans l'être
vraiment dans les faits statistiquement
l'autisme ne touche que 1% des gens je
vais vous citer 9 signes cliniques qui
ne sont pas pathognomoniques oh c'est
pas parce que vous en avez quelques-uns
ou que vous n'en avez pas que vous êtes
ou non autiste dites-moi en commentaire
ce que vous avez un le streaming ou
l'auto-simulation le fait d'avoir des
mouvements répétitifs j'ai parfois des
moments d'absence où je tourne en rond
je tape sur mon genou je saute dans
l'eau continuellement je flatte des
mains fait frétiller les pieds et me
balance sur ma chaise arrache
l'étiquette des bouteilles et les
serviettes en papier ça permet de
décharger son trop-plein d'énergie deux
des comportements alimentaires étranges
rejeter certaines nourritures sans
raison par exemple moi c'est le fromage
ça a sûrement bon goût mais je suis
incapable d'en manger certains vont
vouloir se nourrir que d'une certaine
couleur d'aliments avoir une assiette
uniquement jaune par exemple ou avoir un
plat très ordonné trois des
hypersensibilités ou des
hypocensibilités sensorielles un simple
bruit une étiquette dans un vêtement le
fait d'avoir les doigts de pieds qui se
touchent peuvent devenir insupportables
ou au contraire une douleur devient
banale par exemple moi je ressens très
peu le froid et plus jeune j'allais en
cours à l'université en short tong en
plein hiver je voulais pas porter
d'autres vêtements 4 des difficultés
motrices à bien ressentir encore dans
l'espace ça te rend très mal à droit on
marche bizarrement sur la pointe des
pieds par exemple 5 et des difficultés
d'endormissement avec un rituel du
sommeil très strict il nous faut mes
bouchons mon masque un bruit blanc une
couette lesté très difficile de dormir à
côté de quelqu'un 6 un regard perturbant
particulièrement chez l'enfant fuir le
contact visuel ou au contraire le
maintenir de façon trop insistante les
bébés semblent apathiques sans émotion 7
des difficultés à gérer son humeur avec
des cris soudaines quand la personne se
sent acculée débordée je sais que je me
braque très vite quand il y a trop
d'informations trop de changements dans
mes habitudes c'est pas de l'énervement
c'est de la saturation 8 les intérêts
spécifiques d'être passionné de choses
qui n'intéresse normalement personne
être hyper focus sur les détails d'un
objet vouloir les ranger les aligner à
l'école j'adorais faire des trous dans
mes gommes ou dessiner des centaines de
s sur le cahier neuf et enfin des
difficultés de socialisation notamment
avec tout ce qui est règle sociale non
dites si tu parles à quelqu'un et qu'il
te calcule pas tu sais à son ex que tu
le déranges et qu'il faut que tu arrêtes
et bien je n'arrive pas bien à faire ça
la personne doit me dire clairement je
ne suis pas à l'aise avec cette
situation sinon je vais pas bien le
sentir à sa place on appelle ça la
lexity il y a un dixième point parce
qu'il y aurait la possibilité de voir
l'autisme sur le visage il y a une
sur-représentation des macroscéphalies
légères ou des yeux plus écartés plus
large et d'autres caractéristiques qui
sont assez fréquentes mais pas toujours
présentes à ne pas confondre avec le
syndrome de l'X fragile qui donne un
visage particulier long avec de grandes
oreilles qui est une cause de l'autisme
généralement avec un retard mental mais
c'est spécifique à cette condition
génétique on en vient à un grand mystère
avez-vous déjà vu une femme autiste où
ça se voit vraiment alors oui à Suzanne
Bolle
vous avez d'autres exemples c'est normal
l'autisme est majoritairement masculin
20% seulement sont des femmes
biologiquement on ne sait toujours pas
pourquoi il semble qu'il faille plus de
mutation génétique pour générer
l'autisme féminin il y a même un trouble
exclusif aux femmes qui s'appelle le
syndrome de Rett donc oui il peut y
avoir des différences par le sexe mais
la rareté de l'autisme des femmes pour
être aussi sociale qu'on est intégré
certains aspects du trouble à la
féminité prenez les passions spécifiques
un geek fan d'informatique et de
cailloux c'est bizarre mais une gentille
qui a des posters de chevaux sur
absolument tous ces murs qui lit des
dizaines de romans par mois ça c'est
bien et puis l'éducation féminine est
beaucoup plus portée sur la
socialisation et l'imitation la
stratégie du caméléon ça rend l'autisme
féminin presque indétectable confondu
avec de la timidité de la réserve la
personne ne comprend pas ce qu'elle fait
mais elle sait qu'elle doit le faire un
dernier aspect c'est que l'autisme
féminin est généralement l'IA de
l'anxiété de la dépression confondue
avec des troubles bipolaires et vu qu'on
tendance à beaucoup plus psychiatriser
le féminin il y a de faux diagnostics
qu'est-ce qui cause l'autisme et peut-on
en guérir avant les années 40 on les
appelait attardés où on les confondait
avec des schizophrènes pour eux c'était
l'asile ou la castration pour éviter de
perpétuer une tare génétique puis il y a
eu les hauteur et hansperger qui ont
conceptualisé l'autisme une anomalie
d'une neuro-développement qui peut
prendre diverses formes particulièrement
visibles chez l'enfant dont les signes
peuvent s'atténuer à l'âge adulte mais
persiste toute la vie car l'autisme ne
se guérit pas c'est une constitution du
cerveau mais avec une prise en charge
spécifique
orthophoniste psychomotricien
ergothérapeute on peut corriger
l'expression sociale du trouble en gros
ça se voit moins et la personne peut
vivre normalement moi-même je reste
bizarre mais ça va à 8 ans j'étais
vraiment bizarre on m'a envoyé chez le
psychologue ma mère ne voulait pas parce
que son enfant n'était pas fou super
alors qu'est-ce qui cause l'autisme je
coupe l'idée reçue ça n'a rien à voir
avec les vaccins ou un manque d'amour de
la mère ça existe potentiellement depuis
longtemps depuis la préhistoire en fait
on la détecte dans certaines peintures
rupestres ou même dans des vieux romans
monsieur Darcy dans Orgueil et Préjugés
a beaucoup de très autistiques mais
c'est compliqué de faire des diagnostics
sans avoir la personne en face donc on
est vide généralement en fait la plupart
des autisme se lisent dans les gènes
c'est quelque chose d'héréditaire si vos
parents le font il y a des risques que
vous le soyez aussi et inversement par
exemple chez les jumeaux monozygotes
identiques 98% de ce diagnostiqué
autiste le sont tous les deux mais le
plus intéressant c'est les deux
pourcents restants parce qu'on peut
analyser les différences c'est comme ça
qu'on m'a identifié plus de 200 gènes
associés aux troubles autistiques
principalement des dysfonctionnements
dans la formation des Synaps ou dans la
synthèse de la mélatonine l'hormone du
sommeil 75% des autistes ont ce problème
on a même réussi à rendre des souris
autistes en modifiant leurs gènes ce qui
a causé les mêmes effets peu
d'interactions sociales comportement
répétitifs et hyper ou hypo-sensibilité
aux stimuli cependant l'autisme peut
aussi être épigénétique être causé par
des facteurs extérieurs pendant la
gestation c'est à peu près 20% des cas
par exemple chez les femmes enceintes
exposées aux médicaments valproates
contre l'épilepsie ou à certains
pesticides l'âge de la conception joue
aussi à partir de 30-40 ans nos gènes
fatiguent ce qui augmente le risque de
mutation chez l'enfant que ce soit pour
le père ou la mère s'il semble y avoir
plus d'autisme aujourd'hui qu'hier c'est
une des explications on fait des enfants
plus tard la principale raison étant
qu'on diagnostic mieux qu'on étudie
beaucoup plus et donc qu'on remarque que
le phénomène est bien plus généralisé
qu'on ne le pense récemment on a
découvert que la mutation d'une partie
d'un chromosome est impliquée dans notre
passage du singe à l'humain il y a 280
000 ans et bien cette mutation est sur
représentée dans l'autisme de la à dire
que l'intelligence humaine n'est de ça
une théorie farfelue bien que séduisante
en tout cas le simple fait que l'autisme
était maintenu dans le temps laisse
penser à un intérêt pour l'évolution on
parle d'une époque où ne pas socialiser
était nombreux or les autistes ont pu
être des figures importantes dans les
communautés pour leur capacité
d'ingénierie il y a des anecdotes de
villages pastoraux où les habitants
connaissent l'histoire médicale et le
caractère de centaines d'animaux mais
reste à distance les uns des autres
alors non l'autisme n'est pas un super
pouvoir c'est une caractéristique
intéressante pour l'humanité mais qui
reste handicapante pour l'individu
surtout sous ses formes sévères ce n'est
pas grave que des gens sur TikTok
probablement pas autiste
s'autodiagnostic parce qu'ils aiment
bien les dinosaures et croiser les pieds
sous la couette au fond sa participe à
la généralisation et à l'acceptation du
trouble on n'a pas tous des cerveaux
identiques et l'altérité c'est pas
agréable oui on aime bien être avec des
gens qui nous ressemblent mais on doit
faire société avec quand je vois des
gens sur Internet se faire lyncher et
moquer parce qu'ils sont bizarres mais
pas assez pour qu'on se dise c'est pas
cool de se moquer ah ça doit faire
réfléchir et ce que la personne envers
qui tu nourris de la haine pour sa
différence a-t-elle le même cerveau le
même corps que toi alors oui c'est pas
une excuse pour les autistes d'avoir un
passe-droit je peux peut être un connard
Elon Musk apparemment c'est horrible de
bosser avec lui il est autiste ça
explique beaucoup de choses mais il a
aussi du pouvoir alors l'effort doit
être des deux côtés aux autistes de
continuer l'éducation difficile de la
socialisation on a juste besoin d'un
coup de pouce une société qui comprend
mieux ce mode de fonctionnement et qui
sait réagir et ainsi l'humanité tira le
meilleur des différences de chacun qu'en
pensez-vous dites-le-moi en commentaire
pensez à liker et à vous abonner les
commentaires seront surveillés
évidemment les champs cible allez les
amis Ciao
[Musique]